hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to a brand new let's play of
gray yeah hi this is obviously a newer
game but it's been suggested quite a bit
and the sounds are suggestive that they
might be loud and in my face I don't
know broad credits or something okay I'm
ready to get started it's pretty fairly
fairly highly reviewed I guess couldn't
do anything norm a cold sweat forming on
my brow my unconscious mind begin
forming an infallible nightmare
unfathomable unfathomable plunging down
into the depths I fell
I honestly don't know what to expect I
hadn't heard much of this game before
this
and the last time I got into a half-life
2 mod was in nightmare house two last
night
no it is dark it is like crazy dark I
don't know if it's just designed that
way I don't want to like change the
brightness just in case yeah I think
this is just meant to be like this I got
to get used to half-life controls again
was that oh oh are those heads dolls
heads real heads are those with a real
heads okay alright that's cool
yeah this seems normal just an everyday
thing in my oh my god what is that
who's that ha ha are you what are you
doing is that a knife trust a me oh yeah
we'll give me Oh padded room this is
lovely
oh okay oh oh I want a flashlight I want
a flashlight I don't know if you guys
couldn't I don't know what what have you
done [ __ ] don't talk to me like that
you know who I am obviously not ah no
one's like me yeah Oh ashes floating
bodies in body bags oh oh this is ha oh
I thought it was turning done thanks me
god good God give you hey man you do not
know how to go to the bathroom that is
the wrong way
oh good together ah I thought that saw
ahead this random aah aah aah aah oh so
dark it's no oh what is that oh my god
what is that ooh Wow
good that is not normal I know a lot of
things that are normal and that is not
one of them oh my what didn't quite get
that
holy crap oh man this is kind of
reminiscent of um like the beginning of
afraid of monsters and cry of fear where
things are just going crazy obviously
the main character is going insane in
some way wow this is freaky a lot of
ways it doesn't even look like half life
to it it looks like they did a lot of
custom work which I appreciate
I mean this is like a total conversion
mod or something along those lines off
thank goodness light ex oh ah wait a
minute hang on there might be something
here okay what did that do that one's
still in
all right those are all going in in this
ceiling there I don't know what this is
all about but there's I whoa oh I think
that just unlocked the door not sure but
I'm pretty sure okay I think I got it
all right maybe I don't know I don't
know
oh yeah I'm a gamer skills are just that
good
whoa some of that's going on with a
perspective there oh it's so funky
mirror huh oh how did I not notice you
there like what man this is so cool
freaky but cool oh man I love it love it
to death know what I did it's good don't
just oh don't judge me Oh ball is so
wrong
my head was pounding my hands worked
automatically scrubbing themselves again
and again slowly the thunderstorm within
my head began to recede the bar was
quiet silent even had they closed while
I'd been in the bathroom I lost track of
time
I needed to go to find where everyone
had so suddenly gone get back to
normality something below that said
about explore everything which I'm okay
with doing man that was freaky intro oh
man I'm almost worried they threw too
much stuff at me oh hello baby
ah how you doing yeah come here often
baby yeah oh that's not me oh never mind
I'm gonna lose her in the bathroom come
on get out there and get them ladies
okay all right this is actually kind of
like afraid of monsters again because it
started in a bathroom I mean in a
hospital as opposed to a bar oh wow no I
know what ah wha what is that found one
of Anita's doll Anita Anita must be the
diabolical menace of aha I saw something
it's just a trick of the shadows it was
actually something hey where'd that lady
go oh come back baby it's the women's
restroom no wash my hand Wham
whoa Oh sis I'm grafitti everyone
alright moving forward oh it's so nice
out here but oh yeah I mean seriously
does this look like half-life 2 to you I
mean this looks like heavily modified
Source engine which is everyone where is
it really close up did they close up
that sounds like a voice actor from cry
fear Simon that really does I what is
this this is made by another team in
Sweden does that be awesome stealing
stealing yeah I'm hungry okay enough of
that
all right so exploring the majority of
the bar okay city at war something like
that I'm guessing I can't get out the
front door it's locked I can't open it
what's going on ooh a gun I want it I've
worn it I wanna know I imagine I'll get
a gun later maintenance
I hope I can get a flashlight as simple
at some point in the future
okay
nothing back here I don't like being in
here
bring it on monsters Hey look a little
oh this is disgusting I'm never eating
here again yeah that's right it really
does sound kind of like the same voice
actor of Simon or maybe it's just cuz
all Swedish people sound the same no I'm
just kidding about them huh I can speak
in Swedish - I'm surprised any viewer
from Sweden still watches me after my
horrifyingly bad Swedish impressive high
love to play games locked maybe the keys
are in the office maybe the keys are in
the office
seriously I really think that's either
the same voice actor or someone very
similar ah oh that actually works I
didn't think that was gonna happen
actually do anything really creepy like
nothing's happening
storage is locked and that's the best
way for horror games to start I mean the
big intro with lots of freaky stuff is
cool but it's really about you know the
tension and build-up isn't something I
can get ah hey he's locked from the
other side okie dokie I have a key nope
Oh fairs now let's just see what's
behind his door ha ha ha
I just uh I accidentally have TweetDeck
running in the lake I feel like I should
go to the repair shop
might be someone there it can help me
yeah but the service time under the
house it's the shortest way there well
how about we take the long way there and
not go the way you hate and probably
gonna get us chased by diabolical
monsters from another dimension it's
locked I can't open it I cannot talk we
need who was here this does not look
like a service tunnel hello Oh can I get
a weapon
please locked I can't open it it's the
lock is jammed
okay nothing down here it's hard to
distinguish random garbage on the ground
for something that might be a
potentially useful got me a little
worried ah hello machine shop of sorts
uh huh ooh boss sent me here to get some
replacement drill bits once who's your
boss who's the boss disk hmm if any of
you guys know if this voice actor is the
same I would what what up oh hello
excellent a bolt cutter ha ha a most
excellent
hey bolt cat here now what do I do with
this boss anyway if any of you guys know
if there's a same old voice actor I
would like to know because me being
totally completely amateur voice actor I
mean
that sort of stuff either way nothing ah
that's what I'm supposed to do good
cha-cha-cha get off then the note on the
floor may be stuck dead
it seems so innocuous but somehow I knew
it was meant for me it had been placed
here waiting for my apparently
inevitable arrival the letter gave me
only one clue and address at block 12
still the cursive handwriting seemed
hauntingly familiar I like that the text
goes just long enough for me to read it
and load the next level you just got a
little more ominous hello Oh Oh can I
quit saving this sir quit ah good thank
you
finally something where I can just quick
save on demand because I'm actually out
of time and I'm kind of hesitant to go
down that way so thank you everybody so
much for watching let me know what you
think of gray it's a relatively new game
I mean it's making its rounds in terms
of popularity but I'm always open to
indie horror games like this those are
the free ones free ones are good but
even if it's free I always advocate
going to the developers and donating
some money to them because they deserve
it if they're putting out a game for
free here like I always try to chip in
but if you guys can help too that would
be for now phenomenal I put a link in
the description below of the of the
website where I got it in its place on
ModDB so go and check it out so far I
like what I see so thank you everybody
so much for watching and as always I
will see you in the next part
bye bye